hey what's up guys my name is a Cherno
and welcome to another episode of game
programming game programming episode
three of season 2 so last time we were
talking about how our server would be
set up and how our multiplayer server
what kind of components that would
contain what methods that would contain
and how it would roughly function and we
discredited we ended up just creating a
bunch of methods talking about some java
programming styles and stuff like
getters and setters and a lot of other I
will say Alka ciliary kind of stuff and
today what we're gonna do is just fill
in the blanks for all these methods and
actually create our server right so
we're gonna use Javas networking api i
don't extend here to actually create
something that is capable of sending and
receiving packets of data first of all i
want to thank you guys all for the
support the game programming season 2
has been doing really well in terms of
views and interactions so i'm glad i'm
glad that so many of you are enjoying it
that's really the most important thing
here obviously I don't want to be making
videos that people don't really care
about so thank you for that and I did
just hit 50,000 subscribers so that's
also quite a considerable milestone
halfway to 100,000 which will be pretty
cool so thanks for the support
ok so let's begin the first thing I want
to do here is talk a little bit about
Javas networking API and what it
consists of what we're gonna do just
start off with is use a protocol called
UDP ok and there are two kind of main
networking protocols for sending packets
over the Internet TCP and UDP right they
differ quite a lot but the thing that
the thing to remember is the TCP really
is something that is built on top of UDP
ok these two specifications define a
certain way of how bytes are to be sent
over a stream over a network UDP is
something that is quite a bare-bones
kind of raw way of doing things and then
TCP is something that builds off of that
bare-bones UDP thing and introduces some
other
factors that ensure primarily that
packets are delivered and that the
packet order is actually maintained so
if I send five packets over the network
TCP will essentially is a protocol as a
specification that will ensure those
five packets that I send will be
received on the other end and they will
be received in order okay that's the
most important thing right
whereas with UDP what happens is there
is no kind of I get it like again UDP is
the simple one right there is no
guarantee of anything right what you do
is you say two UDP hey I have an IP
address and I have a port I want to send
data there that's it that's all you do
with UDP okay that you basically just
shove data to a specific destination
it's very much like mailing a letter in
the sense that when you mail a letter
you just you just drop it off at the
post office with an address and that's
it
right I mean obviously you know in real
life and with post if the letter is
undeliverable or something it might get
returned to the sender or might you know
stuff like that might happen whereas
with UDP of course that isn't the case
right you literally just drop it off and
you forget about it now if you want to
create mechanisms that do ensure that
packets are delivered and they are
delivered in order or other certain
things so basically if you do want to
still have that functionality you can
actually implement that yourself
there is nothing stopping you from
actually basically implementing TCP
yourself on top of UDP right you can do
that I mean I wouldn't recommend doing
that because it's already been
implemented and you might as well just
use TCP if you're going for that route
however I'm just that like that's just
how I'm gonna explain it all right as in
it's it's possible to do that because
you know UDP is that kind of baseline
where TCP is built from that being said
games nowadays typically use a
combination of the two
there isn't a CP is a bit annoying or
the recent TCP is and traditionally used
that often in real-time gameplay is
because when packets get dropped
in a game or when you know when certain
packets aren't delivered for whatever
reason could be a network issue could
just be the server not keeping the kit
and not keeping up with the data flow or
something like that it's not really that
big of a deal to actually care about the
packets that didn't make it right
as in think of it this way if you're a
if you're trying to track someone's
location in a GPS and I'm by the way I'm
coming out with all the stuff on the fly
so I hope it's I hope it's acceptable
but if you're trying to track some
location via GPS right and they're
moving in a car if you lose network
connection for a little bit for a little
bit of time right you don't care about
sending those those coordinates of where
they were while the network was out if
that makes sense right as in I want to
know what their location is now if you
drop a few frames or if you drop a few
of a few packets that's alright just
don't worry about them just give me the
out of the most up-to-date one right now
that's all I care about
I want real-time information right
whereas if you were using TCP then it
would you know during that network
outage it would keep resending those
packets that never made it until they
were acknowledged as being received okay
which means that you would get kind of
stale data in the sense that you would
get their GPS location from like I don't
know 10 seconds ago whatever the outage
occurred right whereas with UDP you
wouldn't why because those packets that
didn't get delivered who cares about
them I mean I'm only sending the most
up-to-date ones I don't I don't even
know if they get delivered or not right
obviously you can't implement
functionality where the client says ok
server I did in fact receive your packet
and we will be doing that to some extent
ourselves but again that's up to you
that's completely up to you so hopefully
that example kind of clears things up a
little bit about why like because in
games you know if you're reporting the
position of a player you don't care
where they were five seconds ago if the
network dropped out I want to know where
they are now so if you once you restore
the connection don't worry about the old
daughter
give me the most up-to-date data okay
obviously there is still data like if
they picked up items or stuff like that
that is important or if they try to do
damage but if they're just if they you
know just movement data coordinate data
give
me the most up-to-date one okay I don't
want to see like them freeze a bit and
then have a replay basically of how they
move to their current location no if it
if the network disconnects I want to see
them freeze and then suddenly teleport
to where they are now right because I
want the up-to-date data okay
so that's how it works right and then of
course because of that you know you
might want to do fancy things like
interpolation or other techniques to
kind of minimize the visibility of
packet loss and stuff like that but
we'll get to them later that's the basic
idea
however TCP will like why I say they're
both used is because TCP kind of is also
used for in games for things like you
know sending actual important data
between the seven client right stuff
like items and you know which level to
load maybe in like more important things
like chat messages and maybe downloading
files right if the I don't know like you
might you might have to download like a
map from the server or something now
stuff like FTP and stuff like that that
would definitely be done over TCP
because do you need to have the entire
file you can't just skip segments of the
file right you need to have the entire
file I don't care how long it takes you
need the whole thing it has to be 100%
of it so you do need to ensure that all
packets arrive and in order but for
stuff like you know moving and you know
don't worry about don't worry about
resetting old stale data
I just want real-time data for real-time
data we really do need to use UDP so
we're gonna say this this stuff up I
mean when I'm gonna use TCP at all we
might use it later for chat because chat
is something that I'd I mean you know if
we were if we were making like a
real-time kind of game chat here and I
mean just just text messaging then we
would want to definitely run TCP I mean
we've got two choices right we could
either on TCP or we could write our own
kind of you know UDP thing that ensures
that everything is delivered but we'll
probably just end up using TCP so I can
show you guys how they both work in Java
but with UDP again UDP is really simple
right don't be overthinking UDP UDP is a
lot that there's no like you know TCP
has this thing called a three-way
handshake at the beginning of its
connection right which establishes that
connection and says you know hey I'm
here I'm the server you're the client
are you there great good we can begin
now all right that's basically what it
does because there is that initial kind
of let's connect step UDP know it's like
the postal system right you just drop
off your mail and you say I wanted to go
there that's it I don't know that's it
it's out of my mind it's been posted
that's what happens so our there is no
like established there is no
establishing a connection there's
nothing like that you just make a packet
and you send it to your destination that
is it okay let's do that right now the
first thing we need to do is actually
establish a socket which our computer
will use to send data over the network
right basically what this does is just
ensures that we we have like basically
again going with my postal system kind
of analogy that I'm coming up with on
the fly that I'm sure people have used
in the past a loss because it makes a
lot of sense we need to basically create
a mailbox for our apartment building
that says you know hey we're in an
apartment building which is our computer
I want to be able to say and receive
mail so I need to have a mailbox for
that to happen
otherwise I mean I have nowhere to like
picture this as a mailbox but you also
leave your mail right you don't like
it's not like a post box where you kind
of go out into the syringe some public
air and you post it you leave the
mailbox in your you put your mail in the
mailbox it gets taken and then you
receive mail into your mailbox and then
you can take it right so to do that we
need to do what's we need to create
what's called the data Graham socket now
the diagram part of it use the diagram
protocol by the way is what UDP stands
for the diagram part of it is the UDP
part of it that's why it's called
diagram and then socket is socket I
believe I'm actually too familiar with
Java's TCP API but I believe just socket
would be a TCP socket in fact I'm sure
we can check that right now why do I
never have my sauce attached if you guys
don't know by the way if you guys see
this is a quick tip if you guys see this
and you're not sure how to actually get
the source code all you have to do is
click attach source right and go to
external location path and then look for
your JDK
halation directory usually if you're
only a 64-bit job it'll just be see
Program Files Java get it'll initially
put you in the JRE get out of that you
want to go to the JDK the Java
development kit and then you should see
a zip zip file right in that directory
called source as I say right and if you
just open that you will have the Java
source code so if we go back to socket
okay so potentially it in fact is up to
the implementation right so that's
probably you can probably I guess you
can set up a socket that does evil right
so it's not decided by the actual class
it seems I mean a diagram lock that
definitely is a UDP socket though as
we'll see in a minute
so diagram socket for data gram packets
right which are UDP packets okay cool so
anyway the way that we run this is that
we create a socket this is what our
server does at the beginning we specify
a port when we create the socket so we
do indeed want to actually you know when
we when we start we want to be creating
that diagram socket on the specified
port what time am I on by the way twelve
minutes
all right cool still got a bit of time I
need a what Jacques last video was like
way too long I know I'm sorry this is
gonna be a try-catch thing by the way if
at all let Java let eclipse allow try
that for me so Tsakanikas a new data
Graham socket of course when we start
the actual server we'll set up that
socket this is what we'll use for all
incoming and outgoing connections the
port will be the port and that's all we
have to do
okay socket created again that's us
setting up on our mailbox now that we've
got the mailbox we can send mail so to
do that okay so we set that up we assume
everything goes well if it doesn't then
maybe we can I mean right now we're
printing the stack trace but we can
probably return we can probably handle
that more gracefully by printing
something else to the console like you
know porting news I mean this will do
that anyway but with the stack trace so
and obviously we don't want to start the
listening thread I might just hit return
or something
and then there might be something I
believe socket might even have that
where there might be something called
socket active or socket running I mean
I'm absolutely guessing here is closed I
guess or is connected is this not the
same as is closed what does this close
to so this returns connect state doesn't
equal not connected sure and then does
this see this is why having the source
code by the way is quite useful because
you can actually see what it does
and is closed or as that is closed so
close is actually something completely
different it seems than connected or not
okay interesting but yeah we might want
to do something like you know I mean in
debug mode we might want to assert you
know between like at send for example we
might want to assert that the socket is
connected right well something like that
just to kind of make sure that
everything we do is is actually you know
just just to help us with debugging in
case this goes wrong because right now
obviously we'll start it we will see an
error message but it'll still attempt to
send things even then the socket isn't
open oh you know a more kind of simple
way of doing that would be of course
creating a boolean called connected or
something or active and then obviously
if the if this was successful then we
can set active to true otherwise it
it'll be false by default and it will
return so it'll notice that it's true
something like that yeah it doesn't have
to be too complicated by anyway so let's
cover sending so we've opened up our
mailbox now we can send mail so sending
mail is actually pretty easy because as
I said there's actually nothing really
here that we need to do except for just
say that you know we don't need to
establish any kind of connection with
our client or without host nothing you
know we set up our our mailbox and then
we just put a letter in there so to do
that we basically just have to create
something called a diagram packet and
the diagram packet is our letter right
it's our piece of mail so a new diagram
packet man this mail analogy is really
perfect
happy that I thought up that I came up
with it right now because honestly like
a lot of these videos are just me I
don't have the time to actually kind of
do pre-production on these so I kind of
just hit record and hope for the best
so sometimes my video is kind of go well
sometimes they don't though so yeah
alright so diagram packet takes up a few
things the one that we'll probably be
using is this one right so we have a
byte buffer we have a length we have an
eye net address and we have a port okay
and this is of course whether like
picture this as again you're writing a
letter yeah you have to specify the
actual content of your message right so
the actual letter in this case that
would be the byte buffer and the length
right so you specify well you know this
is programming this is computer science
you actually have to have to specify how
long the like how much you want to send
off that buffer and then of course the
front of the letter you have to put in
your address and your port right which
in this case is just your address so
we're basically sending this block of
data I'm going to assume that we're
going to send the entirety of it so I'm
just going to say Delta length again
just for future you might want to break
it up into like smaller packets maybe
four kilobytes maybe one kilobyte
something like that up to you and then
of course you could do that by just
checking to see how big that is first
and then breaking it up into chunks
before sending it totally acceptable
right now we're going to assume that
this isn't going to be too big and I'm
sure that this may break it up into
smaller packets for you anyway but again
the more packets you break up the more
packets can get lost and you might have
issues with that as well so just
something to keep in mind that for
larger sizes you know I wouldn't be
saying you know you mean thick because
theoretically you could specify you know
a gigabyte of data here but clearly
that's not gonna be able to get sent as
a single packet so you might have to do
stuff to break that down which you could
do client-side or you can manually do
inside here because you know how big it
is anyway so we have the length we also
need the honor address so when we send
something typically a good idea with
that is to actually have a place to send
it to so I'm going to create at least
one version of send here that takes in a
Niner address and a port okay and then
of course in this case we just had an
interesting port here and that's it our
packet has been created and then finally
what do we do when we want to send that
packet which is our letter we put the
letter in the mailbox so we say mailbox
or socket dot send packet and that's it
that is how you send a UDP packet over
the network in Java it is extremely
simple very straightforward because
again it is straightforward right
there's no guarantee there's nothing you
need to setup you just drop your letter
in there and off it goes hopefully why
not
but that's the risk you take with the
postal system that is common like modern
networking I guess ok cool so there we
have that one thing I will note as well
is that as far as these things go if we
jump over into our server yes here if we
were to send something I mean right now
we do need to specify the data the
address in the port you know as far as
addresses go there are a few ways to get
that I believe there's something called
address let's see get by name ok so this
will potentially there's something that
will create an honor address for you
from a string it might be this one but
that doesn't look like it because that
looks like mm-hmm
interesting I'm not 100% sure how that
is supposed to work exactly hmm but yeah
that this shoe I mean there should be
ultimately there should be something
that just lets you specify a string I'm
just not sure where it is in the API
where it lets me specify a string and
then you can basically just end up
sending something to that address maybe
just get my name
get my name I think it is that so for
example if I was sending something to my
local IP like to a server on my local
network and the address of that server
happened to be I don't know after that
right I would create that I would create
my port for that server which you know
as we all know is gonna be a one line -
obviously I mean in this case you know
we are the server so pretend this is the
client I guess I've got a client on this
IP address I've got a I've got my ports
which might be the client support which
could also be eight one and two whatever
and then I have my you know might be
sending a few bytes of data so we'll say
something like you know 0 1 2 right we
got 3 bytes of data there we've got an
address by sending it to which is this
so we'll say address and then we have a
4
all right now unfortunately this as you
know Java likes doing will throw an
exception if it doesn't work I had it
when I just hate the whole exception
situation I just don't like exceptions
but anyway all that aside so basically
if it can't decrypt this like if we were
to write something ridiculous here like
that or if I was just gonna you know
write something like shadow and then
that it couldn't you know use DNS to
resolve that or something then it would
tell me that it doesn't know what the
host is then it would return that ok our
local host of course will be 127.0.0.1
otherwise known as a local host that's
you know what this IP address would be
so if I had both the server and the
client on a single IP address they would
need two separate ports of course
however the IP address would just be
that so this is an example of where this
is actually a different machine
different computer on the network acting
as the client slash server ok
so there we have it a full example of
how to send something this will actually
send the packet okay if I run this right
now
you can see that I don't actually get
any errors now I don't know if it
actually sent that on all because we
have that listened thread I assume it
did I mean one way we could check is we
could put a breakpoint in here okay cool
so it looks like it does so it sends it
everything's fine no exceptions exits
okay and of course our application here
keeps running because we're still
running that listener thread but that is
how that works okay so we just
successfully send to three byte packets
to a IP address that probably might be
my printer which is off currently so
pretty cool right great that's going to
wrap up this video hope you guys enjoyed
watching as always don't forget that you
can obtain all the source code for these
videos by simply going to well you're
gonna have to first of all go to
patreon.com for slash the channel link
is in the description and pledge at
least $5 per month and then you have
access to all of that
you basically have access to a private
github repository which looks like this
and contains all of the code for each
episode okay so this will both contain
the entire code for just rain in general
right so all the code that i've ever
written for this game including all the
graphics and all 126 episodes of the
game programming series all the code is
absolutely here on github available for
you to to grab if you would if you are
so inclined also it helps to support the
series and make sure that I can keep
pumping these videos out every week as I
am currently doing so of course I'll
support there is greatly appreciated and
keeps the show going otherwise of course
feel free to hit the like button if you
guys enjoyed this video leave your
thoughts in the comments below next time
we're going to take a look at how we can
receive packets of data and yeah and
we'll kind of keep this ball rolling so
yeah I'll see you guys next time thanks
for watching goodbye warm